on faisait beau bernard à marrakech la
pète tout la brève ah ouais j'avoue
témoin et les anglos les montées à bord
neuf dès début mai ce flou je retire
doucement mais sûrement prenez le
meilleur locaux et croyez-le ou non il
n'a évidemment rien notamment à 7 des
gammes de la tête d'un vainqueur
l'allemand perd dans ses chaussettes
bleues là c'est bien moi c'est bien mais
l'attaquant des gunners
[Musique]
ça me regarde et qui hélas son côté
écolo ça même du vélo tu de rambo bah
ouais c'est magnifique
le sport y a que ça de vrai get en vélo
rien rien et dans la rue voilà a battu
fait un bisou à temps
c'était l'ère mon chou weight aussi mon
coeur balance ton post je regarderai
indirecte à l'avion
[Musique]
trop peut-être suffisant et de mon ami
louis jean de jane's
tu es sexy
[Musique]
au japon rose
lise tata suzanne tabac maintenant j'ai
pas d'argent mais tu vois la magnum le
maître de maison ça devant un peu qu'est
ce qui se passe chez chant pop en ce
moment voir à balard pop art tout ça
c'est l'avenir
un magnum ouais ouais bien sûr nous
avons le système peut nous avons le fils
neveu le fils sarkozy
nous avons également le jeune et plus
[Musique]
à haute feet of the day petit buzz
petite jupe en jean et veste en cuir et
petit manteau te dis je l'appelle le
teddy bear un nounours j'ai encore une
peau de l'ours en fait
[Musique]
alors d'après la mousse nous sommes sur
le bon chemin
[Musique]